Tony don't it's the chief executive and
he joins me now so Tony how big is this
fine potentially the initial estimates
are somewhere between 1 billion barrels
and 2 billion barrels in place and then
of course we need to optimize the
recovery from that in place oil so
world-class world-class by any standard
and what price does the oil price have
to be for this for you to break even for
the recoverability to be profitable the
location of this discovery is shallow
water it's close to the Mexican coast
conveniently located so we expect this
to be a relatively inexpensive
development it will take some time to
fully evaluate but I would hazard a
guess that somewhere in the 25 to 30
dollars about break-even it's pretty
Genie above that both the Mexican
government and of course our own
consortium should be able to make
profitable venture now they look how are
your shareholders our individual private
investors I guess they'll be I mean
they'll be pleased today because the
shares have gone up substantially but
they'll probably be wondering am I gonna
have to stump up more capital to get
this stuff out of the ground
yes I'm particularly pleased I have to
say for not just shareholders but also
our other state stakeholders as you said
earlier it's been a difficult period for
the oil industry as a whole
volatility and indeed the relatively low
price over the last 2 or 3 years many of
our shareholders have stayed with us so
today is some reward for their loyalty
we hope only the beginning of a recovery
in our fortunes and for the industry as
a whole and what's like doing business
in Mexico I mean no foreign company for
years has been able to even explore in
Mexico how did you get in there I mean
full credit to the Mexican government
they took the political decision to open
up their industry to the international
oil industry after many years of full
state control and they took that
decision in an environment where the oil
price was falling and and therefore the
initial reaction from the majority of
the oil industry was to stay on the
sidelines we took the opportunity to go
in there and picked up actually the
first license in 2015 and today's
discovery is indeed on that license were
early days in developing the
relationship
during the International Organization
government but I must say all our
dealings with them so far have been very
fair and very encouraging and very
briefly any of you on the oil price I am
Boris you'd expect me to say that I
think but I can see that they've been
there hasn't been enough investment in
the offshore oil industry in the last
two years
meanwhile demand continues so in the
medium and long term I remain bullish I
turn from premier oil good to see you
thanks ago thank you